listen when you've trained naturally for
20 years right the second the needle
enters your epidermis right you feel
like things have changed whoa it's
different now that instant I don't do
drugs per se like right well you're
sober you've been sober for years 20
years yeah inside steroids don't break
your sobriety
if they were personality into changing
or like
um what's the word mood altering sure
we'd be in a different conversation what
about Roy Bridge
is more I'll be honest with you I seem
very reserved he's the most common Zen
person you've ever met in your life he's
like he's like Buddha if he was on
steroids like if Buddha was reject yeah
prednisone is the only steroid that's
ever given me Roid Rage
why did you get mad
I don't know anybody anybody anybody
I'm not asking